celebrity chef todd english is gracing
our kitchen to talk pride specials and
father's day feast
within his foodie empire the english
hospitality group welcome fun hi good to
see you thank you rocky great to be here
so excited and you know other than it's
100 and whatever out there today yeah if
we're inside a night school studio well
you're used to being in the kitchen
where the ovens are on right
you're used to the heat i like the heat
bring the heat baby that's what i love
yes okay now you have four restaurants
just here in las vegas
they're all delicious but how are they
all different
is what i really are different and i
think you know the thing that we really
pride ourselves on is the fact that you
know we are bringing something a little
bit different to the community here you
know obviously it's a big tourist
community as well so we're the virgin
hotel with olives which has been amazing
and
yeah olives i've been out here since 98
since steven brought me out here to
bellagio most maybe you have out there
have gone i don't know maybe maybe or
not if not now you have an excuse to go
bellagio gardens yes it was beautiful
and then we had um
also i have uh the beast at area 15
which is a fun interactive kind of
psychedelic fun experience and we do
find really fun food and then we did
also um
uh and then also i just opened up my own
hotel
the english hotel
wow with the pepper club there which is
sushi and mediterranean food it's really
fun kind of i hope that we get to get
you down there at some point you don't
have to ask me twice you don't have to
ask me twice okay so let's get to the
fruit because this is a beautiful spread
obviously let's start with pride it is
pride month what is your special pride
day well this with this well we have a
pride dish we actually have these really
cool colorful buns made with all master
colors this is actually made with uh
red cabbage beets and then i uh like a
cilantro basil so this is all natural
colors okay so that's really fun and
that's cool i'll make a couple of these
here we have something to do with the
beast but you remember it's also
father's day yeah i know and i am very
proud i am the i am the yes the proud
father of three amazing children my
daughter's a chef she runs the test
kitchen at william sonoma my boys are
doing amazing stuff i tried to keep her
out of it but she you know i said i
didn't even know you were paying
attention you know but she's so cool and
where she got it from where she got it
from so we have uh we do a big we do a
big emphasis on barbecue
and i love barbecue i grew up in the
south i'm a little bit of a southern boy
in atlanta atlanta georgia
and um and then uh so it's so funny
because i mean i just love barbecue so
we do a big barbecue program at the
beast okay so that's one of our big
stars i love the beast and obviously
it's father's day you take your dad to
the beast you can take them all over
area 15. and it's a whole night it's so
funny because when i think of father's
day you know we always think well meat
steak you know but in this day and age
there's a lot of vegans and we do vegan
very well so you can also if you're one
of those dads that is on a vegetarian or
vegan diet we're happy to accommodate
you in any way
now where can we get
these these special dishes whether it's
for pride or father's day are they at
all your locations or no every one of
these is different this isn't the pepper
club it's our teriyaki steak or short
rib i should say this we're doing a
special uh
uh
skewer of lobster and steak as well with
a sweet and sour glaze baked potatoes
and grilled corn
this is a dessert
it comes
you might want to try it
you might want to get that and that's it
that's all you are are you a chocolate
fan yes i can there you go i want to try
it i have a fork here somewhere oh my
gosh okay if people want to make
reservations at any four of your
restaurants here in town right what
should they do what's the best way best
way is uh rising.com we can go there we
can uh there's many different ways we
can you know you can get there online uh
to go to our website www.todd
www.english.com
okay anyway any any of those work we
have a fork here no i can't find a fork
but i have but i see something i don't
need a fork for so i'm going for it this
is the pride slider what do you call
them that is the bright sweater
and they can order this where it's at
the beast so that is the beast right we
do we specialize in barbecue we do a lot
of things with that so
uh the buns again all natural delicious
we're gonna under that
yeah that's that's that is smoked
overnight eight hours smoked yeah we get
a nice hickory a little mesquite in
there we make that all happen so wow
that's good we have some brisket we have
also our homemade sausage and uh and
then we have a little beautiful
chocolate dessert as well this is our
chocolate fallen cake been on the menu
for a long time at olives and is
delicious and wonderful somebody get me
a fork guys
i'm so tired usually i've always had
that okay it's fine it's fine we're just
happy you're here here we go we got it
for you thank you okay well mercedes i'm
gonna send it over to you and i'm gonna
go ahead and finish this feast oh man i